so I am a she and I'm gonna be your
guide today as we explore the world of
deep learning in JavaScript a world that
is still very squishy and still rather
being born so I'm not a machine learning
expert sorry about that but my mom is or
I think she is she's worked in the field
she's an audiologist by training and she
did work in digital filters for hearing
aids and then later worked on the
acoustic model of the speech recognizer
so I remember working in her lab one
summer and people were saying all of
these very strange and quite
intimidating words and there were all of
these odd sigils up in the wall and it
was kind of overwhelmed at the time I
didn't understand basically any of it
this process has also been a process of
getting closer to her where I can now go
to her and be like a mom I actually
understand him across entropy is and she
can be like that's great can you explain
it to me and I think I can and I think I
can explain it to you so that at the end
of this talk you too will know what it
is well enough to use it so I've been
learning deep learning
out of curiosity with some excitement
for the future and also with the sense
of existential terror that the robots
are coming and they're going to consume
all of our jobs and possibly our
societies and maybe ourselves we there
might be this matrix pod person
situation that's going to happen and I
have some exciting news which is that
the robots are very very impressive and
they're also kind of stupid like stupid
in really fundamental ways and so
they're probably not going to take your
job at least not within the next year or
two but they are going to change it and
change it quite dramatically and so now
it's a really exciting time to be
getting into this field there's a huge
amount of research and a lot of new
tooling available to us so let's dive in
and before we dive in I want to give you
a single definition because I gave this
talk and a student was like so you said
tensor like a hundred times and that's a
very scary word so what does it mean
because I
you'll tense right now so a tensor is if
you look it up on Wikipedia you find
this definition that's like a tensor is
a like numeric field that is closed over
some free operation I would say that a
tensor is a block of numbers and so we
can have a block of numbers that is
actually just a single number and that
is a ranked 0 tensor or a scalar we can
have a block of numbers that is a line
of numbers a vector or rank 1 tensor
matrices number squares or number of
rectangles are rank two tensors we can
have these number rectangular prisms
which are rank three tensors and on and
on into higher order tensors that become
progressively harder to draw so I'm not
going to draw them and I've just defined
tensors for you because I'm about to
talk about tensor flow which is
currently the state of the art machine
learning framework formerly just for
Python and C++ and now available in
JavaScript so let's sort of break down
what's available in the Python C++
findings and what's available in
JavaScript so in using the C++ API and
using the Python API we can run math
operations these very large graphs of
math operations on the CPU on the GPU to
be able to do more operations at a
slightly lower precision in parallel and
then on the TPU which is like a GPU but
with even more even crappier compute
units and this is special purpose
hardware that Google made that is
optimized for doing machine learning
particularly it turns out that machine
learning is a large stack of really
simple operations and so being able to
parallelize over very simple operations
is ideal the JavaScript bindings
currently give us an CPU computation
under node and then the web bindings use
WebGL to perform
soon the node bindings the tensorflow
team promises will use the C++ back-end
which means that we should have
performance parity with the Python
libraries currently the WebGL bindings
that use the GPU are about half the
performance of the C++ library which is
unfortunate but you can do it in the
browser so that's pretty cool the other
important part about doing machine
learning research and developing these
models is the ecosystem around around
the core processing libraries that we're
using and the ecosystem in Python is
enormous and the ecosystem in JavaScript
is sad and that's ok and if you're if
any of the propeller folks or anyone
doing scientific computation in
JavaScript is here I want to say your
work is wonderful and I'm really looking
forward to it and the the size of the
community is currently small but if the
history of JavaScript frameworks is any
indication we will quickly build up a
large and interesting and powerful
ecosystem of software it's just
currently the case that if you want to
build your own extremely large deep
learning models and train them on the
kinds of data sets that you might need
to train on multiple computers in order
to access then you're probably going to
be doing that in Python in the cloud but
then you can take those models and this
is the exciting thing about tensorflow
j/s you can take those models and then
run them in the browser which means that
you can leverage the power of machine
learning in the browser without sending
all of your users data off to some
provider in the sky and you can also
continue to train those models locally
we can do something called transfer
learning where we cut off the last bit
of a model and we adapt it while not
having to retrain all of the models deep
layers in order to give users machine
learning but the advantages of machine
learning without the privacy
implications or the entanglement of
surveillance
okay so I just said model like 500 times
what exactly are models so let's say
we've got this phenomena happening in
the world and this phenomena is a snake
or is a drawing of a snake and we want
to model it we want to understand it in
some way we want to simplified version
of it that's what a model is it's a
simplified version of the world turned
in to math so in this case we're going
to turn our snake into a squiggle with
machine learning we go through this
training process where we want to find
the set of model parameters that lets us
fit the world as best we can and so we
could imagine just trying different sets
of parameters like different squiggles
kind of at random until we find when
this sort of works on the snake it's not
really ideal right we like could sit
here all day we don't have a great
metric for how well we're doing and we
don't have a sense that we're making
forward progress so what we'd really
like is to find a way to pick some set
of parameters pick some squiggle and
then iteratively improve it sort of do
what we would do naturally while
improving upon our own knowledge of a
situation until we find a good fit and
we can do that through a process called
stochastic gradient descent which is how
basically all machine learning models
are trained and if you're a machine
learning expert in the audience yes
there's a variety of gradient descent
techniques we're gonna look at the
simplest one right now so let's say I've
got the splatter of paint and I want to
model it if I actually wanted to model a
splatter of paint I would almost
certainly not do it as a line but I'm
going to do it as a line because lines
have two parameters which makes them
quite easy to visualize all of the like
various things means to visualize for
them so I'm going to model the splatter
obtained as a line and we're gonna be
happy about it first I'm going to throw
a coordinate system under it and I've
turned these into XY points
I'm going to dig back into my repressed
memories of high school and specifically
high school algebra to remember that the
equation for a line is y equals MX plus
B so that is I've got two parameters
from our model M which is the slope and
B which is the y-intercept so if I pick
just random values for those two
parameters I'm gonna get a line any two
random values will get me a lion this
line is not a very good line so this
point is like way off and these two
points are pretty off and if we go
through and figure out that often ASET
of examples then what we're looking at
is a quantity called loss loss like that
sensation you feel at the end of a long
relationship is a measure of how badly
we did how poorly our model fit the data
it's a kind of machine learning self
flagellation
and a common kind of loss that we use
specifically in particular for
regression which is what we're doing
right now called mean squared error that
means that we take the average of the
difference between the model and the
ground truth squared if we were to write
it in JavaScript it would look something
like this we could reduce over our data
signs the difference between that data
point as our model predicted it and the
actual value of that data point square
it divide it by lens and then that gives
us this function that we can pass in so
we have this lie in higher order
function we can pass in model parameters
here and any two model parameters are
going to yield a particular loss with
respect to this data which means a hut
because we have two of them I can
visualize it on a plane and say that
okay this is going to be the slope of
our line it's slipping this this is
going to be how high up off the x axis
it is B and for some given
set of model parameters in fact for
every given set of model parameters
there's going to be some loss so what we
can do now is we can go and figure out
what that loss is and then sort of poke
around up there and be like what if my
line was slippier what about less slopey
what if my line was higher up what if it
was lower up and in one of those
directions we will be reducing loss and
so we're gonna take a step in that
direction along both axes and then we'll
do it again and be like okay more slippy
less slippy higher lower
and again and again so at each step
we're using loss to point us in the
direction of movement as we all do as we
improve upon ourselves and as our robots
do as they improve upon their selves
loss is showing us where to go and it's
revealing for us a landscape of loss so
the what we're kind of doing is we're
finding the slope of this landscape at
each point the general Matthew term for
the slope of a landscape is its gradient
and so the process that we're doing is
gradient descent we're just kind of
rolling down this landscape like rain
drops into the valleys that are closest
to the ground truth so there's a lot of
ways we might tweak this process one is
to notice that if we're computing loss
against all of the examples all of the
splatter is of paint then it's going to
take a while it's not going to take that
long for a line and XY points but if we
have much larger models then it can
become quite expensive to compute loss
and so we might just grab a handful of
examples randomly stochastically you
might say if you're the kind of person
who says stochastically rather than
randomly in order to compute the loss at
every point so that gives us stochastic
gradient descent other parameters we
might tune are for example the size of
the step we take that's something called
the learning rate so these these
quantity is the size of the batch like
the number of examples we
at or the learning rate they're not
learned we don't train them and so
they're not called model parameters but
rather hyper parameters which is a very
exciting word I think and the model
doesn't learn them during training and
said we said it manually when we train
the model typically by running hundreds
of experiments and staring at graphs
until our eyeballs bleed okay
so that's a lion it's like a very simple
very simple function probably not very
useful right there's other functions
that we might use for deep learning for
example we might use one of a set of
sigmoid jewel functions these are
designed to kind of simulate the ooh
simulate the firing of a neuron we're
down here the neuron is not firing up
here the neuron is firing and they're
smooth because they because that way
they are differentiable at every point
and so for a long time when I was first
looking into machine learning this was a
very common thing when if one of the
bunch of trigonometric functions or
strange functions that include e were
used as the activation functions for
individual neurons because they were
mathematically kind of complex to think
about but very well behaved and then
around 2015 there was a paper that
basically was like no no what if we just
what if we just used this function which
has a fancy name it is called oh no my
slides okay so that function is called
the rectified linear unit often
abbreviated relu and it is a very hard
function as a very complicated function
it is the max of X and 0 that's it
and that function is pretty easy to
think about we could imagine writing it
in less than one line of JavaScript
and it turns out that that's simplicity
and that ease of computability makes it
perfect for deep learning where again we
are not doing very interesting or
complicated operations we just sure are
doing a lot of them and so we can
imagine stacking up these rectifiers and
here we're going to have four layers
than earth for neurons densely
interconnected in two layers and because
they're densely interconnected we're
going to say that each of the neurons
and the second layer gets fed by all of
the neurons in the first layer so this
one for example its input is going to be
the weighted sum of inputs from all of
the neurons in the previous layer which
if you think about it because of the
shape of this function what we're really
doing is nesting if statements were
nesting if statements with conditionals
whose values depend on the output of
previous if statements and whose
thresholds are basically entirely
hard-coded next time you see like
researchers at Google have created a
deep neural network that does some
impressive thing just think researchers
at Google have figured out how to
hard-code 50 million random values in
order to do some impressive thing which
is basically what's going on I mean the
impressive part is obviously that the
training process figures out those
hard-coded values for ourselves but at
the end the thing the model is doing is
basically a giant pile of spaghetti code
which fortunately models our brains
pretty well so even for a model like
this a relatively small one if we think
about the number of interconnections
between these two layers of four-runner
ons we quickly see that we've got
sixteen of them for a line we had two
parameters and we were able to think
about it's lost landscape this model has
16 parameters and I don't know about you
but I have a really hard time
visualizing 17 dimensional surfaces
but of course it it gets worse so what
we're seeing revealed here is a
visualization of the lost landscape for
resinate ResNet is an image classifier
and ResNet has about 60 million
parameters which means that this is
obviously like a heavy approximation
like these folks have done some really
interesting projection in order to get
it to even resemble something
three-dimensional it's been said of the
terrifying things that live at the base
of the sea and will one day wake to
consume the world that they have length
width depth and several other things and
perhaps this is what Lovecraft was
talking about all right the good news is
you do not have to train those models
you don't even have to think about those
models or hold their lost landscapes in
your head because you can end him and
spell them and let's look at that of
course if you want to train those models
I highly encourage it so we're gonna
look at an example of transfer learning
where we take a pre trained model and
then train it to do something else which
lets us leverage all of the training
time on like the larger in this case
image recognition model and then use it
for a different problems but problem
space so we're gonna do transfer
learning and what we're going to do this
is actually an example you can go and
pull it up on github I'm going to play
pac-man using my elephant friend
Tallulah that's Tallulah and the way
this works is I pick a bunch of examples
just using my webcam that represent the
images for up down left and right and so
I'm rotating Tallulah I'm trying to like
be in the frame and trying to not be in
the frame I'm trying to like get a
representative sense or give the network
a representative sense of where how I'm
gonna be holding her which as we can see
I do not we're gonna train it our loss
goes pretty low
and then when I play then network is
going to highlight in yellow which which
direction and thinks I'm moving and we
can see that it works pretty well at
least until I start getting stressed
about pac-man and not holding Tallulah
in the same way I was during training at
this point I am like subtly freaking out
incidentally if you want to ruin a
friendship using your friend as a
controller is a pretty good way to do it
and now I'm eaten I've been eaten and
I'm happy to report that we are still
friends okay so let's look at how this
example works thing one we do is we well
things zero we do is we npm install
everything including tensorflow
so thing one we do is we import
tensorflow
from tensorflow tfj is the new hot thing
is namespace packages these days and
then we're gonna load up the model so
this model there are models that you can
also npm installed this particular model
is just sort of served off the web
somewhere and because we're doing
transfer learning we're going to kind of
do a little bit of surgery on the model
so we're gonna pull out this layer con
pw 13 relu whatever that means
we're gonna look at what that means and
then we're going to construct a new
model that has the same inputs as mobile
net but outputs that low but not final
layer the actual final layer of mobile
net is going to be like two hundred
probabilities namely the probability
that this month that this photo contains
a cat the probability that this photo
contains a cow the probability that this
photo contains a laptop and on and on
throughout whatever classes of images
mobile meth has been trained to
recognize we want something before that
something where the image has been kind
of reshaped into some arbitrary chunk of
interesting data but has not yet been
winnowed down to what it contains
okay we'll look at that more in a second
so we load our model we grab that layer
and then when I'm adding examples this
is what's happening we're just throwing
them into this controller dataset which
is building up a data set of examples
and then we construct our model so our
model is going to take the output of
that layer of tensorflow it's gonna
flatten it and it's going to run it
through a configurable number the
default is 100 densely interconnected
relu neurons and then at the end we're
going to have a soft max layer soft max
is a different activation function which
is useful for when you want a
probability distribution so in this case
we want a probability distribution
num classes is going to be 4 because we
have up down left and right and that's
all we're trying to decide between so
the output of our network is going to be
the relative probabilities that I'm that
I am holding tallulah up or I'm holding
her left I'm holding her right and so on
so then we configure an optimizer we're
here not using stochastic gradient
descent the classic stochastic gradient
descent we're using Adam which is a
stochastic gradient descent technique
that is better it's a little bit smarter
about how it the size of steps it takes
we're going to compile this model with a
loss function and that loss function is
hi mom categorical cross entropy which
is a useful loss function when you're
dealing with probability distributions
the reason being if we have this example
which is an example of me holding
tallulah upside down to indicate down
and the network predicts this which is
technically it's predicting that I'm
holding her right how bad is that really
because this is like it's pretty close
the prediction is wrong if these were
flipped it would still be kind of wrong
that it thought that there was a 10%
chance that I was holding her correctly
you know so answering that question is
what categorical cross entropy
it's basically like how how much did
this model confuse different probability
classes and now you know okay and then
finally we call fit this actually goes
and starts dispatching stuff off on the
GPU and we got these callbacks every
time a batch is finished so every time
we have computed our loss for something
we've updated the weights and then we've
taken a step alright and to play the
game we ask mobile net to do its
prediction we run its prediction through
our model giving us one of four
probability classes and then we figure
out which one is the most likely and we
do it and that's pac-man that is
transfer learning with sensor so J s I
would like us though to go back and
understand what it is that we're getting
out of mobile net and to do that I'm
going to load up mobile net load up that
JSON file that we saw us loading earlier
in the browser and here we'll see that
there is this is a Karass model Kerris
is a machine learning framework that
lets us describe a deep learning system
as a bunch of layers and here it's
layers come on click past a sheet click
alright so a deep learning network that
recognizes images typically looks
something like this we've got
convolutional layers and normalization
layers and activation layers the
activation layers we kind of know what
they look like there are those relu
activations that we saw earlier
normalization layers just ensure that
our values are roughly between 0 and 1
ish and they do it across single batches
which is why they're called batchman
layers convolutional layers have all of
these configuration parameters and like
many things in machine learning they
sound very hard but are not very hard
convolutions are basically Photoshop
filters so if we have a whole bunch of
input pixels a convolutional layer is
going to grab some chunk of those input
pixels run it through a filter
produce an output pixel and it's going
to then walk the filter over the entire
image producing an output image you can
you'll notice that if we do this without
allowing the filter to slide off the
edge then we'll get something slightly
smaller we can decide what it is we want
that's one of the many tunable
parameters so convolutions comment all
kinds of shapes and sizes this one is
three by three and the key thing here is
this filter which is the same across the
entire image and is trainable which
means that actually let's just see what
it means so I've gone and gutted mobile
mat and put it here and this is what's
happening in each of those many many
convolutional layers that we saw before
and yeah it looks like a bunch of crappy
Photoshop filters because it is a bunch
of crappy Photoshop filters but the
interesting thing here is that the
network has sort of started to do things
that look like edge detection and other
processes that are trying to basically
mimic the informational extraction
things that happen in our visual cortex
this happens naturally this happens
naturally when you train a system that
is able to create these isolated filters
on an image classification task that
mimics the kinds of image classes that
we ourselves recognize is it starts to
do the same kind of processing that we
do which is an interesting validation of
the model I think so I hope this makes
deep learning a little bit less scary
the realization that it's just a big
pile of operations a bunch of spaghetti
code that's been tweaked by a very
simple but big process
um and I hope it makes it seem less
scary because the world can seem a bit
scary these days a world is flushed with
information and our interaction with it
is heavily mediated increasingly by
machine learning systems the systems are
not perfect they've been trained on
whatever data we've given them and just
like us they internalize the biases of
that data and just like us they can be
pressed into the service of whoever
wants to wield them there's this proof
that neural networks are Universal
approximator is which means that any
function you give them they can
approximate to some level of precision
and if you believe that our own compute
our own cognition is a computable
function then we're moving into a world
in which the fundamental tasks of
cognition are now things that we can
train a machine to do so these are not
real faces you probably figured that out
already
these were dreamt up by again a deep
learning network whose loss function is
another network the two networks improve
each other learning to dream up things
that appear to be people and this is not
barackobama
this is machine learning generated Obama
synced to a recording of an actual Obama
speech and of course there exist systems
that can generate speech that sounds
like anyone as well so how do we cope
with this with a world where we can't
trust our own eyes and yours one way is
to ignore it and to say that these
technologies are not that good yet but
if cognition is a computable function
then our societies and ourselves our
games and robots it turns out are very
good at playing games in the history of
computation we see these tides so first
all important work was done on big
mainframes and then processors improved
and work moved to personal computers and
then networks improved and we put
everything in the cloud and now we're
seeing the tide go out again
as we begin to realize what we've given
away and how much power there is and
knowing everything about everyone and
how much danger there is in us relying
on opaque boxes outside of our control
to feed us with knowledge so my message
to you is that these technologies don't
have to be opaque and they don't have to
be centralized and
we can hold the power of robot minds in
our pockets we can use them to create to
not just create forgeries but to discern
truth so this is just the beginning
everything we've seen here today I think
it's quite impressive and I think it's
going to look downright embarrassing in
a few years when you can talk with your
robot assistant and the pattern of your
voice will never leave your wrist thank
you
[Music]
[Applause]